بعد هذا العنوان الجريء الذي نشرته صحيفة ناشونال إنكوايرر في يناير / كانون الثاني ،
كشف
جيف بيزوس عن علاقته مع
مذيعة التلفزيون السابقة لورين سانشيز ، وهو
تطور مذهل جديد أجراه
محقق بيزوس منذ فترة طويلة
لمعرفة كيف حصلت صحيفة التابلويد على القصة التي
أدت الآن إلى ادعاء محدد للغاية حول
المملكة العربية السعودية جافين دي بيكر في كتابه
The Daily Beast
خلص محققونا والعديد من الخبراء بثقة عالية إلى
أن السعوديين تمكنوا من الوصول إلى
هاتف
بيزوس واكتسبوا مصحح معلومات خاصة ، وقال إن فريقه تحدث
مع قائمة طويلة من المصادر بما في ذلك
خبراء استخبارات الشرق الأوسط ومستشارو ترامب.
ونفت مصادر في
الناشر الأمريكي لشركة إنكوايرر التي يديرها
صديق ترامب القديم ديفيد بيكر آمي
الرابط السعودي الذي قال لشبكة CNN
التجارية إنها اعتمدت على مصدر واحد فقط لقصة مصدر واحد فقط
لشقيق سانشيز مايكل
سانشيز.
أن المواد لتقريرنا
كانت  تم الحصول عليها بمساعدة أي شخص آخر
غير المصدر الوحيد الذي
أحضرها إلينا لأول مرة ، ويقول Debecker أنه بينما تمت مشاركة
النصوص والصور المرسلة من Bezos
و Lauren Sanchez مع
Inquirer بواسطة Michael Sanchez ،
علمت صحيفة التابلويد بالرسائل قبل
الاقتراب من Sanchez ، فإنه يعتقد أن
كانت الحكومة السعودية هي مصدر تلك
المعرفة ، لكنها قالت إنه لم يكن واضحًا
ما إذا كانت أمي على علم بتلك التفاصيل ،
وما يشير إليه ديبيكر هو أن
السعوديين ربما يكونون قد أبلغوا المستفسر
، ثم ذهبوا إلى سانشيز ، وفي الواقع
قال سانشيز إن المستفسر جاء
بالنسبة له ، ليس العكس ،
فقد اعترف سانشيز بتسريبه إلى
المستفسر لكنه ادعى أنه تصرف بدافع
الدعم وأخبر الصفحة السادسة أنني لن
أبيع أختي أبدًا كل ما فعلته
هو حماية جيف ولورين ديبيكر الذي
عمل لعقود مع المشاهير
بما في ذلك  لم تقدم Cher Olivia Newton-John
و Cosby's وفقًا لصحيفة New York
Times أي
دليل ملموس لدعم h  هي مزاعم
لكنه قال إنه سلم النتائج التي توصل إليها
إلى المسؤولين الفيدراليين ، حيث حولت مزاعمه
ما كان قصة رديئة عن
الحياة الشخصية لأغنى رجل في
العالم وصاحب صحيفة واشنطن
بوست إلى لغز جيوسياسي بيزوس
وفبراير بوست على الوسيط.  يشير ضمنيًا إلى أن عامي
حاول ابتزازه لإرضاء ترامب أو
الحكومة السعودية المستاءة من
بيزوس بسبب التغطية اللاحقة للمستعمرين المقتولين
جمال خاشقجي ، وأنكرت الحكومة السعودية
أي صلة بآمي
بيزوس وكان المنشور
أهدافًا متكررة لنيار ترامب أمازون.  يريد
نفوذًا سياسيًا حتى تستفيد أمازون
منه ، فهذا ليس صحيحًا